if you want to stay relevant on YouTube
and keep getting results you definitely
want to pay attention to the Trends on
YouTube however many of them are
overrated so which ones matter and which
ones should be ignored video podcasts
what do you think things underrated chat
GPT for Content creators you're gonna
lose your job like no you probably got a
handful of years left Andrew Tate
properly rated I heard one person
actually say that he's one of the
greatest content creators of all time
in this episode of the think media
podcast I'm back with Omar and Nolan and
I'm excited to talk about overrated and
underrated YouTube trends I'm ready uh
the first one is just YouTube itself is
it overrated or underrated YouTube is
highly underrated it's usually not the
first platform people are trying to
attack I think it's
good energy yeah it's underrated I think
that it's mainstream now it's accepted
but the average person still
has no idea how much opportunity there
is for regular everyday people to build
a brand get their message out make side
income and even recently
the signing of the NFL and getting the
NFL ticket and some of those things
YouTube
continues to grow and so I think the
future of YouTube is very underrated I
100 agree and this is a really cool
article from hoot sweet uh in 2022 this
came out and this is across all Android
users
um I don't know why you gotta ignore the
iPhone users like that but whatever uh
so you know still a good pool but um
they found that YouTube was the most
time spent of all social media apps and
this is actually like by far so it
clocked in
23.7 hours per month this is the average
time per month yes people are spending
on YouTube that's insane that's that's
like a day a month yeah that's like it's
probably I probably double that or more
but that's maybe for for the week week
ones that are not strong with the
YouTube Force YouTube is my TV like
that's what I consume yeah it's crazy
yeah so I want to bring up second
channels Iraq has now this little Vlog
channel uh Ryan Trahan uh Creator
support Connor Samir they're starting a
new channel
so what do you guys think about second
channels I think I think starting a
second channel is I mean it depends on
the season but it's underrated because
you can just have the systems in place
to be able to have something on a
separate Channel it allows you to a lot
of times be a little bit more creative
because you're not you don't feel so
boxed in but I think more people can
actually do it if they just have the
right systems my take is that second
channels are
overrated for small and new creators too
many people that are just starting are
thinking about starting two or three
channels and I think that's the wrong
move you should start with a focus the
creators you mentioned are established
they have momentum they've got resources
they've got money
and 100 agree with Omar as well that it
could be a part and should be a part of
your YouTube Journey
but should probably be avoided on your
YouTube day one what I would ask you
what about think media what in you felt
like I need it's time to start a second
channel do a podcast
I think that starting a second channel
for the think media podcast versus think
media
part of it was the Simplicity of the
audience because a lot of times I think
people subscribe to think media because
of camera reviews and video editing
tutorials and the strategy
business-minded Creator marketing tips
build a business is different than that
and there was enough difference and then
following that line of thinking starting
from scratch devoted calling putting
podcast in the actual title there was
then layered reasoning I do think that
if the audience was the exact same that
it would have been possible to
potentially keep it on the same channel
my next one was video podcast and this
just goes well with what we're talking
about with with your channel but in
general video podcasts what do you think
I think it's underrated I think I think
people should give it a shot as one of
their content formats you know with the
option to Vlog do a talking head video
do a live stream do a faceless video
video podcast it's just
um I don't know it's more conversational
a little a little less heavy on the need
to edit and I think it's worth a shot as
far as packaging information in a
certain way now I don't I don't believe
just because you're good at something
you speak with intention
um the I think it helps for a lot of
people that that are like really good
Educators or good communicators but it's
just a cool way to start get some
friends together get your wife or
whatever and just talk on camera it's
cool yeah or hide your wife hide your
kids and then get the homies together
and start a video podcast but I mean
ultimately I think people should go to
youtube.com forward slash podcasts with
an S it may or may not pop up if you're
outside of the U.S but that not only is
an aggregate page of YouTube organizing
podcast but there's now a banner there
where you could see multiple shows that
are almost being advertised like you
would see over on Apple podcasts and
some insiders DM me recently about
YouTube's agenda for podcasts like it's
just going to be a big deal and so I
think it is one of the biggest
underrated strategies and opportunities
for people listening to this right now a
cool thing that a friend of mine said
too he wanted to or he did he
interviewed his grandpa for an hour and
a half like just another there's a cool
thing I mean even if it's just for
yourself to keep and put somewhere but
like interviewing people that you may
not be able to interview ever again and
just actually talk through some stuff
there's just so many cool things you
could do with a I did that too yeah oh
you did yeah
we call it a legacy video we got the
idea from the Kardashians and they were
filming like their grandparents and I'm
like
we we sat down and we uh started filming
my wife's grandparents and
um just to have that just hear their
story and so cool Legacy videos are
underrated yeah I think getting wisdom
from the Next Generation the wisdom
passed down getting into conversations
with your parents while they're with you
as well as to be able to learn from them
and whatnot I never knew this but
Madeline my wife her Grandpa had a
perfect bowling game and it like changed
his life forever and he's like sharing
the story and it was just unreal like it
got him all these scholarships and stuff
I'm like just yeah anyways so I
completely agree super cool what about
thumbnails I think thumbnails are
properly rated I mean I think they're
respected properly they're the most
talked about and debated aspect of
YouTube technical tweaking and uh color
theory color theory there's a Twitter
account that literally just has like
thumbnails and then it like shows the
different like colors in there yeah
people are deep yeah so I think you
could almost argue they're overrated but
I don't believe that's true they're so
important I don't think people are
underrating them I think they're
properly rated
yeah I I mean I'm trying to from the
from the newer creative point of view I
I do think they I don't know they make
it's it's usually like they do way too
much like I don't know if they I think
they overrate it on their approach when
really like we always teach Simplicity
no more than three elements in your
thumbnail and so there's a level to it
not like yeah and then you know we have
a story of a video that dropped that
didn't even have a thumbnail and it
performed amazingly but because Google
Chrome and even on your phone the videos
start kicking in so it's becoming if
anything it's it's airing toward a
little bit more overrated if you're
starting your videos pretty strong I
think video ideas I think the topic
matters more most the time than the
thumbnail and the title I think that
might be the most important part of
packaging in just my opinion and uh so
for that reason when it comes to video
ideas I think video ideas are underrated
I don't know if you guys agree with that
but I wanted to group those together
thumbnails titles video idea this is
what you know we talk about the
packaging
um packaging in general even is so
important but I wanted to get your
guys's thoughts on those three things
idea thumbnail title where
what's most important there I agree with
you topic is most important because
sometimes people they get too far the
ball's too down far down the field and
they're like why is this video not
performing it actually I put a lot of
effort in editing it it's clear
and even the title was good and the
thumbnail was simple but you're like
yeah but does anybody care about the
subject matter so so topic is your big
opportunity and even if you fail on a
lot of other points but pick the right
topic and deliver decent value it can
perform incredibly well because you just
cover the right Topic at the right time
and you understand what viewers want
Andrew Tate
Andrew Tate is
properly rated
I wonder if people know who Andrew Tate
is
if you know who he is
I think he's properly rated if you don't
know who he is I still think he's
probably underrated I heard one person
actually say that he's one of the
greatest content creators of all time
and I think that whether or not you
agree with his views he's definitely
controversial and polarizing people
could be critical of that but anybody
who becomes the most Googled man for a
period of time has figured out how to
get attention which is one of the goals
you're trying to do with content
creation
he knows how to communicate his ideas
um he knows how to trigger people and
get people talking and certainly many of
his messages are spreading so I feel
like one of the most underrated
opportunities for creators to get better
is to learn from people they don't like
and to be able to eat the meat and throw
out the Bones from if if they weren't so
sensitive and didn't get offended at
everything they could say okay it this
may not be my world view or my beliefs
but what can I learn from this person
and then how could I ultimately use that
from their vantage point maybe for good
and so I think that there's a lot to to
learn from agitate I also think he's
over hyped in some cases that's why I'd
say properly rated how about you Omar I
mean I looked at you so hard
um you know I I feel like for
you know they're just I mean it's cool
to like study somebody like that and you
know I would say the guy that would used
to do all the ads with the books tyke is
it Ty Lopez I always say tight Cruz but
like that's not the right guy Tai Lopez
but uh he it was just like he'd be like
the modern era of that he he figured out
the time and place of things and how to
uh create virality and um and yeah
there's just things you could pick as
you know as far as picking aside being
polarizing but I don't know I don't
I didn't I didn't care much about the
guy I mean as far as like I was
wondering you know a few weeks in just
like what what did he do like what did
he do wrong and then I don't know just
how he became mainstream it's kind of
crazy
[Music]
this video was brought to you by stream
yard stream yard is our go-to platform
for streaming to YouTube and Facebook
with an incredibly easy to use interface
for built-in branding transitions text
lower thirds and seamlessly bringing on
guests it really is one of the best
options when it comes to live streaming
and what's so cool is they've
implemented a brand new feature called
local recording take control of your
audio and video with local recordings by
separating out your audio and video from
your guests this feature gives you the
control over your content for later use
making it perfect for podcasts and video
creators just go to streamwoodthink.com
to get started now
how about viral videos I think viral
videos are overrated
I agree yeah
I think that viral videos are also
dangerous to a Creator's health
because
one
you may get 15 minutes of fame but if
that's all you get then you're not gonna
have long-term success
two Book of Proverbs says an inheritance
gained two early in the beginning won't
be blessed in the end
so sometimes going viral can actually be
harmful to your psychology it's all it's
like drugs it actually quite literally
is drugs to your brain the serotonin and
dopamine and emotional experience you
can have from going viral can make you
delusional being delusional is not
helpful the effect of a viral video on
you could make you prideful being
prideful over the Long Haul is going to
lead to your downfall and so I think
that at the same time
I'm all for let's get as many viral
videos as possible but slow and steady
success is much more practical much more
healthy and uh avoiding those extremes I
think also can lead to a much longer
career it's really good yeah I mean I
think the idea of just to go viral 100
overrated and you don't want to
accidentally go viral for the wrong
thing like whatever what happened to the
Mexican dude on the skateboard drinking
cranberry juice like I don't know like
cool though like he had a little um
Island Boy like what happened to those
guys yeah they just you know they pop
smoke but it would I think it's Brock
Johnson who teaches this concept vfm is
it viral for me yep so you can have the
right viral you know you know you make
the right video for the right group that
makes sense for what it is you want to
be known for that's a beautiful
combination and that usually just comes
by showing up consistently and not
knowing that this video struck a chord
or you made a you know a reaction video
that the right time about you know the
real estate market or what have you and
so I think there is a level to just like
just aiming for the consistency more
than it is the virality and you will see
some nice little fires pop off of that I
like this topic you know I think I think
that it also maybe depends on who you're
talking to if you're talking to a brand
that wants to get the word out about
their product then via a viral video is
a great thing to pursue because you know
what your end game is the most eyeballs
possible for that that's great I think
where you might get into more danger is
you talk about a personal brand and even
potentially there's a generation of
people right now that are chasing views
I think chasing views is a terrible
Pursuit I think if you're chasing impact
if you're chasing building something of
significance and Views is part of the
equation but it's not the main thing and
that goes back to you know sipping
cranberry juice and being on a
skateboard word if I'm just trying to go
viral on YouTube shorts I'm just trying
to go viral on Tick Tock unto what and
there's some people they're not even
sure they're like I don't know I thought
that's just what we're all trying to do
I mean where's this all going so I think
a little bit more thoughtfulness in
terms of what it is you're trying to
build and I think that if people think a
little more deeply that again
we've experienced viral videos at think
media here and there but we also always
come back to the slow and steady so
they're a nice little kick in the pants
they're a nice little boost in the brand
they're a nice nice little kick in the
stick
no I don't know about that no it's funny
is like we have a friend who like is
pretty a big uh personal brand on social
media on every platform and Ryan Pineda
yeah I'll just say the name why not no
but he has a tick tock coach and his
coach will tell him like Hey talk about
what like a random thing because the
random thing gets you in front of so
many and then you have majority of your
stuff to be the the reason why people
know you for what you know but at least
they met you because you talked about
Panda Express you talked about watches
you know you wore those booty shorts
like that was the thing he was actually
told by his Tick Tock coach hey where
boot wear short shorts and bright
colored shoes on your necks and put the
camera like shooting up like if you
watch some of his videos okay and and
usually when they make these tweaks on
Tick Tock they like they work wow I
don't know but then I don't know booty
shirts underrated but you know here's
here's what's interesting because I know
Ryan and you know Ryan and what I love
about him is because of knowing the big
picture he wrote a book called The
Wealthy way which is all about you know
family and Legacy and wealth meaning
like happiness and joy and impact and
generosity
so Ryan
is trying to go viral but has a big
vision and Legacy that it's all unto and
that's what I'd be challenging people
for when you isolate virality for
virality's sake I think it could be
overrated but I do think because by the
way I would I love that you say some of
those things because I would be happy to
try I I got to try the booty shorts
thing the booty shorts
technique booty shorts you go running I
mean you're like halfway there I already
got them yeah I just need to actually
I'm in I'm into it but also the impact
we want to make is is bigger and then
even our more practical level like
what's the bigger business model what's
the bigger brand what's the goal as
opposed to just trying to like jump on a
trend anything the thing is that it
doesn't end at the end of that that
video the point is it's it's a top of
funnel to get you into a deeper world
that you have yes what you guys are
saying I think is purpose is underrated
because if your focus is just on views
if your focus is just on money
it where does it lead to that it never
ends and that's one of the things I love
working at think media is the purpose
the faith just behind what we're doing
helping people and um and I think
you guys said it you know that is
underrated
yeah so batch shooting videos I want to
talk about that next can you explain
first though like what it what is it and
then just talk about if you think you
know who should do it or should more
people do it yeah batching is the
concept of compiling the action of
creating in a one-time sit-down and you
could batch your scripting process you
could batch your thumbnails we did that
today you can batch shooting videos
because you batch the planning now I
think
um I think batching is underrated I
think I think people aren't thinking uh
wise enough with their time and if you
are a busy individual or if you're
you're trying to make a YouTube channel
happen with a part-time or full-time job
maybe a family that batching should be
your best friend and so I think it's
underrated just for that way of thinking
it's a really smart way to think as a
Creator how can I create more content in
less time and we do you know there's
many ways you can do that like this
video podcast even today today is a
batch day we flew you in and
um but we we want to use our time wisely
because there's so many other things we
could be doing but the powerful thing
about video is I believe there's no
greater multiplier of time other than
video so if you can make videos in less
time you're creating an asset that's
going to work a thousand times over
based on the views or the reach that it
can get and therefore keeping that in
mind will actually probably make you
think batching is more important than it
is maybe currently in your content
creation and I agree with Omar but also
I think to present a contrarian
perspective I think in today's world
batching can become overrated
and for this reason that you over batch
and you miss out on the opportunity to
react to things in real time our mutual
friend Vanessa Lau talked about this
because she focused entirely on getting
like eight 16 weeks ahead or something
and then was not able to talk about
things that were relevant and trending
in the now I think that the cure for
that is to include batching in your
process but then to have additional
opportunities to also jump on Trends
that's why I love live streaming is to
maybe see an article drops or new
feature drops and you can get that out
quickly while there's also a batch in
the queue and I my propensity is
sometimes too over batch we did a
thumbnail batch today and I brought
literally your whole wardrobe my entire
wardrobe which was completely
unrealistic I brought you know every
article of clothing that I own thinking
that we were going to shoot thumbnails
for the next three years and uh I might
have been overdoing it so I think you
can over batch that is is the idea you
should tap into it but it's not
everything there's also something about
creating real time when you respond and
when you feel it and that might be the
other thing is that sometimes sometimes
sometimes some of the time
the best content is when you're coming
well always the best contents when
you're coming from the heart and
sometimes it's hard to get into the
emotional state
of something in a batch context it's a
lot of different emotions whereas maybe
you read something you see something and
it's in that moment that you should
create so you want to be ready to
capture that inspiration in the moment
as well so it's not either or you should
batch but you should also maybe create
content when you feel the fire I
absolutely love creating from
inspiration like when I just feel it I'm
like
thing like I watched the Casey neistat
video and I was like dang I wanna I
wanna commentate on how he creates
videos it's very simple but very
engaging and people can achieve this I
don't know I felt inspired didn't really
even need a script like it's kind of
like uh it's cool to be able to to be
able but the batching I see it it allows
me to be able to be freely creative like
that too there's one other thing on
batching I think the world is different
today than it was a few years ago and
that is a fact
but here's what I mean because we've
been talking about this stuff for a
while and so four years ago we were like
batch well four years ago there wasn't
really vertical video there wasn't
YouTube shorts there wasn't the green
screen effect on Tick Tock or on YouTube
shorts to where you can now easily
screenshot an article and then green
screen and react two hours after it
comes out so I think that's the other
thing is to say what content format are
you creating I think that a piece of a
Creator's
Empire should be their batch consistent
show potentially that has more of an
evergreen appeal and then there's also
other content formats notably vertical
video which could be made uh we started
a 10 minute countdown during one of our
live streams during our Challenge and so
uh we met as a team we started the
countdown and then I got on Google News
found an article screenshot the article
set it up plugged in my little iRig mic
filmed a 30-second commentary on the
article
saved it posted it as an Instagram reel
and then jumped on and was still able to
do that in 10 minutes and so I quite
literally had a shot clock I had to be
ready
um and was able to pump out a vertical
video in less than 10 minutes and so
it's both and I think that that's a
different content format that doesn't
take as much uh you know maybe four
planning like you planned out this
episode so okay we've exhausted this
topic but I want to move on to YouTube
shorts which you're talking about
um and
you know today is February 1st which is
when we're shooting this and um today
something cool happened which is
YouTube's paying us for ads that are
happening on YouTube shorts and so we
don't know what that looks like we might
know in the next couple days if it takes
as long as just the regular ads do but
uh so this honestly answer could change
you know but right now I do think
YouTube shorts are underrated I think
the the best case scenario with YouTube
shorts is the viral aspect which we
touched on but actually what I found on
uh this YouTube channel that I started
from scratch was that uh one million
views on YouTube shorts actually got me
three times more subscribers as one
million views on my long form video
that's really interesting
um and so we see someone like Mr Beast
who feels like you just hit 100 million
subscribers he's already 130 million
subscribers I don't know the analytics
of where the subscribers were coming
from shorts but he's posting shorts
those are going even more viral getting
even more views even more subscribers I
am on the side that they right now are
still highly underrated without going
into all the little details of you know
why you know what it's used for and you
know some people it's just a topic that
people like to argue about but I think
they're underrated yeah I mean I I
honestly I don't have a full grasp on it
you know like I'm like what kind I'm
seeing people have find their way in it
one uh Chris Ramsey a magician he only
posts iPhone reels or iPhone YouTube
shorts but his content content is super
cinematic clean and crispy and he found
that that just works you know people
like the the the real relatable stuff
but yeah I mean I I still I mean we're
still beta testing too it's it's new
it's new so maybe maybe you would land
on the underrated part just because yeah
I think they're underrated for sure I I
think that
um and I I think that in our community
because I always want to add value to
the think media podcast
I hear Too Many people counting them out
or avoiding them I think because we can
become resistant to change and we can be
I just don't like them well okay fair
enough but like is it about what you
like or is it about what's effective and
is it about are you falling in love with
a Content format or are you actually
thinking about what's your mission
because if it's a tool to help you
actually make an impact and Reach people
and if it could be a gateway to long
form which is what YouTube themselves
have said they're trying to achieve and
they're continuing to tweak the
algorithm so that as shorts get
awareness recommendations back up your
long form videos I think that it's a
mistake
to ignore YouTube shorts
on the topic of new change
what do you think about chat GPT for
Content creators
or AI in general for Content creators
underrated
and I think it's a mistake for the
people who are saying it's overrated
some people like oh it's hype it's not
that great no it's a big deal like and
this is also just version 1.0 this is
now public AI That's just kind of
hitting the marketplace for some it
might seem a little gimmicky you know
for example I uh I said hey Chad gbt
write me a hip hop rap song about
YouTube and personal branding
in the voice of Notorious BIG
and it did it but it definitely was not
Notorious BIG and it was not good so
then I was like in the voice of the
Migos it did that as well and it was
like the same song it was nothing even
different and it was like worse and then
I was like in the voice of J Cole and
again it that Nuance was not there now
that'd actually be pretty wild because
we're talking about like all-time
artists and lyricists that are rhyming
syllables and all kinds of different
things that are happening so it's it's
cool I mean it's a cool utility I think
that uh I do think it's underrated
though and I I I'm tempted because I
think I just saw Tom bilyeu impact
theory he just dropped his take on AI
Alex from Ozzy video was really good and
I think Caleb Ralston our friend you
know had a lot to do and he DM me that
one it's also kind of like everyone's
jumping on it but I think that's
a proper response to how big of a deal
it is yeah no I think it's underrated I
I mean sometimes you just have to you
know I contextualize the world of
YouTube and influencer stuff it's still
a very small percentage and so I feel
like it because it's not mainstream it's
not really people are still you know
copywriting you're gonna lose your job
like no you probably got a handful of
years left you know like but you can use
it to speed up processes that's why I
think it's cool like that's always been
the beauty of time you know our parents
had to go to the libraries and re go
through many books to get a little bit
of information and then we had Google
and that was beautiful and now we got
chat GPT so shout out to the Future yeah
some people say that chat gbt will
destroy Google
and what do you think I don't know
I was like I was like is it maybe yeah I
mean it's cool it's really really cool
and I've been using it for just coming
up with video ideas and stuff for what I
do but yeah you still right now need
that human element to filter those and
so I'm excited about it though and I
think people should be exploring it and
I think it's underrated because I was
just sharing uh Chad gbt and then also
like open AI image all this kind of
stuff with um some people who have never
even heard of it didn't even know it
existed and so a lot of people you might
be hearing about it for the first time
and it's going to make your life easier
so I'm excited for it what do you think
about Community posts on YouTube the
community tab
darn well may be the most underrated
feature on YouTube
now I think I'd say that you do need a
decent following for it to to uh get
results for you like because they're
giving it out now at basically any level
if you qualify people with 26
subscribers can get the community tab
yes and so you just have to uh their
tribe tab yeah you just check a couple
boxes and you can get it it takes like a
week and then you have it I feel like
you need a couple hundred subscribers to
a thousand for it to be interesting why
I call it really underrated is because
when we're in like our YouTube boot camp
coaching program or whatever I go to
People's Community tab when we're doing
Channel reviews and a lot of times it's
a ghost town and some of these channels
are established they may have 8 000
subscribers or 16 000 or six hundred
thousand and there's just so much
opportunity there you can post up to
three times a day
effectively you could even do more but
like effectively so long as it's
valuable and engaging you're not just
marketing you could do polls there you
could just ask a question and get a lot
of feedback people can shape the vision
of your next video you can get honest
feedback about a last video The Creator
who understands the viewer best wins and
the community tab is this chance for you
to understand your community better get
insights get data get feedback one of my
favorite things to do is if something's
on my mind if I have a question I love
to just quickly take it to the community
community Tab and then check back like
okay I wonder what our audience would
think about
these three video ideas and which one
should I make next turn it into a poll
that's so powerful we're stuck between
what title would you be most likely to
click on you think you your intuition
has it maybe it confirms that which is
nice because now you have more
confidence or maybe it goes an entirely
different direction you can do polls
with little square images which are kind
of more fast thumbnails with this but
they're so tiny but still it's still a
little bit yeah really good feedback and
it's helped boost our click through it
and then you also can send traffic to
your email list or to other things and
off platform and so yeah it's it's just
uh it's definitely underrated it's
underutilized and it's also used wrong
in a lot of cases for example if you
just link to a video on the community
tab with just the YouTube url that is
the worst performing type of post versus
uploading a square image that's maybe
different than the thumbnail that's just
kind of interesting and stops the scroll
with a clickable link it can perform 10
to 50 times better and we we've tested
this extensively so yeah I think uh I
think it's underrated what about the
first 30 seconds of your video
we call it the hook
um but basically it could be the first
five seconds ten seconds 30 seconds
you're opening I I think it's overrated
to feel like you need to over edit for
it
um because you can you I think you can
get right into the content and that's
that's a great way to approach it so I I
think I think that the thought process
behind it I think you don't have to
stress yourself that you need to spend
two hours on that first 30 seconds of
editing just make your content better in
the first 30 seconds but even that's a
strategy though which is getting into it
quicker and there's a lot of people
don't do that though 100 yeah but um I
get what you're saying because typically
when I'm doing hooks I'm like I am doing
the other strategy of I'm trying to
tease what's coming up I'm trying to
show uh what you're going to learn in
the video or transformation and I'm
really spending a lot of my time usually
my scripts the beginning of the video
I'm scripting word for word and the rest
of it is just bullet points and the
reason for that is I know for me I know
how important it is and uh just based on
a lot of people in our community I think
that is one of the things that I want to
call it underrated because I think a lot
of people miss out on they're not even
doing what you're doing which is like
you'd be better off not even doing a
hook not even doing anything in the
beginning if you just get straight into
the content uh and so for that reason I
I'm like it's underrated and people need
to realize just how important it is I
agree with that but I want to go back a
little bit too like the community post I
think it poses a a picture of the
Creator the one that complains about how
people aren't engaging with their
content and platforms give you the
ability to you engage with your audience
and yet you don't take seize that
opportunity it just goes to show where
you're really at you know like don't
don't ask for engagement on your videos
or you want it if you're not even
willing to engage your community that's
already there strong thanks so much for
checking out this episode if you want to
check out another one then click or tap
the screen can't wait to see you in a
future video peace